just over a week ago Michael and I were
here talking to you about stadia based
on our pre-launch experiences and well
now the thing is launched and we've got
a lot of thoughts to give you some good
some bad my pain has changed a little
bit we're gonna get into a lot of things
right now
this is Stadium in 2019 Michael how has
it been since we last chatted it's been
it's been a mix of things I think that
in in the first video I kind of talked
about latency and image compression
that's the thing I always talk about and
we'll talk about it again here you wanna
shut up about I won't because to me I
think that that's the most important
thing for me and I'm sure a lot of
people out there are concerned about
that as well so and now I've also again
like I said I'm playing in optimal
conditions through wired connections and
it's it's been mixed in that regard but
it's been mostly positive is what I'll
say having played a lot more destiny to
having played Wolfenstein Youngblood as
well that these are shooters where those
things are going to come to surface and
I've been largely impressed by that it's
not perfect it's not the same as playing
on a console or PC local hardware right
it's passable it works well yeah and
like the narrative out there is that
stadia is all you know bad news and
stuff and it's like I mean we can get
into why that is but but generally
speaking it works really well I would
say the most impressive experience I've
had in the last week has been playing
thumper yes supper is a rhythm game it's
very demanding it's a sort of thing that
like you know when it's all working well
firing on all cylinders you're pretty
much oh I do I get lost in the gas and
all I want to do is just kind of keep
living in that world and that's exactly
the experience I had I mean it you know
the timing has to be right and it is and
it works and it doesn't stutter and like
what more can I say thumper works really
well on stadia and it's not the only one
but it's a really good test yeah you've
also played a lot of grid I have to how
to create as well and that was a little
bit less consistent so a few nights ago
I was playing for about 45 minutes felt
pretty good I was able to play a few
races I even found one competitor online
a real person wow that's that's a
difficult thing about stadia is that
there are not many people online so if
you're trying to matchmake and a game
like grid or find opponents and like
Mortal Kombat or Samurai Shodown it's
tough but I found one we were racing
sort of like I was saying with thumper
it was great it felt good there were
moments where this was at home playing
on the Xfinity connection it would like
almost drop out and get really glitchy
this was maybe once every few minutes
and it would be just for like a second
or two that was kind of the only big
problem but today I was playing a few I
was playing in the the campaign mode and
I would finish a race out of like a
series and it would freeze on the
results screen I would have to exit out
of stadia reopen it this is all in the
Chrome browser to keep playing and
luckily it would pick up where I left
off but it's that's a sign that there's
still some kinks that have to be ironed
out yeah but yeah for the most part I
think that input lag is it's been
largely addressed for my concern now the
big game that the stadia came out with
was that we have Red Dead Redemption -
yeah and now talking about image
compression and like image quality that
Red Dead Redemption - is a game that
needs to be you need to see the finer
details to really embrace and enjoy that
game so the visuals are very much part
of experience as any other aspect of
that game and especially if you notice
right off the bat when you're playing
the the opening sequence which is a
you're covered in snow you're horseback
riding and the the environmental fog
just how like how immersive that is to
put that moment is supposed to be yeah
like I am lost in the snow yeah that's
really hard to enjoy when the snow and
the fog are like blocks of color that
it's I had the same thought I was
playing it and I was almost like wait
this is fitting because I'm not supposed
to see what I'm supposed to see but I
wonder if this is as strong an effect as
it should be yes so that's to say that
there's like visual artifacting yeah
where there's the you could see the
compression you can see that you know
playing through a stream isn't gonna
give you the best image quality and I
noticed it playing destiny but I'm not
that's not my concern playing that game
sure so when I'm exploring environments
that are supposed to look amazing with
Red Dead Redemption - Brett said the
game ran well it just didn't it didn't
look great and
yes even in like games that are darker
too so I think about a wolf it's not
Youngblood I mean you're stuffing in a
lot of dark areas and stuff and you'll
notice that there and it's it's it's
it's a noticeable thing and I think I
said this in the last video that image
question had become a bigger concern
than input lag has and that's still true
now are you talking mostly about playing
on like your you know PC through like a
Chrome browser or I'm yeah yeah I'm PC I
should probably mention that this is
1080p on 1080p displays granted it is a
wired connection so through a Chrome
browser I I imagine that you know
conditions are as you would want and I
would kind of expect better than that
yeah I playing in a Chrome browser
myself with Red Dead at home I noticed
actually like beyond the compression
stuff you're talking about almost the
level of detail when it comes to the
polygon models it seems to haven't
dialed down like I was noticing a lot of
things that just looked almost last gen
and it was a little bit concerning but
the moment I put it over on the
chromecast ultra yes playing in 4k that
all kind of went away and it looked you
know better than it did it does on my
ps4 Pro which is saying a lot which is
also to say that you know stadia can be
really good yeah like it's not it really
depends on the conditions you're playing
it in and that kind of brings me to an
underlying issue I still want to talk
about a few more games but I think we
have to address the fact that being a
stadia customer and trying to enjoy the
you know plethora of games is like short
of a few a couple dozen right now you
have to spend a lot of money these games
are really freaking expensive Rid which
you've seen behind us $60 game you know
there are some deals for pro members
that are gonna last until December 3rd
don't know what games are gonna cost
after that I mean I guess it gives
Google a chance to pivot and maybe
reprice a few things but the bottom line
is that you know you can't count on
having the same experience across your
phone across your browser and across
your TV so you really have to be buying
into this this ecosystem this idea of
completely flexible gameplay
- I think justify spending the money you
have to spend for stadia because yeah
the games are expensive but you're also
spending a hundred thirty bucks for a
controller so you mentioned playing on
chromecast ultra so you can use your 4k
TV and in the previous video we had some
concerns about what the ecosystem is
like when you're controlling it through
a Google home app on your phone and
kicking it to stadia and what the
relationship is between all those apps
and has that worked out for you and has
it been easier to use chromecast ultra
it worked out easier I have to say no
because I was trying to switch from a
previously like wireless configuration
to a wired one and again the same issue
existed where I had established it as
connected to my Wi-Fi and the controller
which also has Wi-Fi enabled is
obviously a key part of this that has to
be in the same network that worked fine
but when I did go to plug it in I had to
wipe all of my settings and from there
you have to you know god it's it's
really complicated you have to connect
your stadia account through Google home
which is like they're two separate apps
and then you also have to connect the
controller but my controller wasn't
found right away on Ethernet I actually
walked away from my couch and
frustration like how is this not solved
for launch
sure I wouldn't did something else and I
came back and then I could see that it
was like hey we found your controller
and I was like oh okay well I guess it
took a minute but it shouldn't it should
be seamless it should be right away so
kind of knowing yeah it really drives
home that this is effectively a beta
test sure in a lot of ways yeah I think
yeah it's important to address the
chromecast ultra stuff and that what
that ecosystems like because when you do
buy the fountain those who bought the
founders edition or the premier edition
or the premier Edition this thing is
being sold with chromecast ultra and
this is the all again still the only way
to play TV games in 4k yeah but once you
get over that hurdle honestly like
that's kind of it and then it just works
so I know for most people they're just
going to set theirs up maybe they have
to change their settings once like I did
but once you get it going honestly it's
pretty great yeah it's pretty wild to be
like oh I'm gonna hit play yeah couple
seconds later game is booted and it's
like you know the most updated version
of the game you don't have to wait for
any downloads you don't really have to
tinker with any settings which you
wouldn't do on console but these are the
PC versions technically yeah so I think
Google has made that promise about like
if what you set it up you hit play and
you're in that is working as intended
yeah the thing I'm still struggling with
I think when it comes to like you know
these devices working as you imagine
them like obviously connected to a cell
phone you would expect it to work over a
fast cell phone you know connection
still can't do that you still have to
have your controller tethered with a
wire to your phone and connect over
Wi-Fi and I've yet to play on a Wi-Fi
network other than my own at home that
is seamless so I still feel like I'm
tethered to my home I don't feel like I
have this completely portable flexible
stadia experience yet I hope it gets
there that'd be really cool not every
games students are playing on mobile
like I tried playing Youngblood on that
the pixel three gave us an a beautiful
phone but it's really hard to play a
first-person shooter on that at least
for me but something like Final Fantasy
15 Tomb Raider even grid to an extent
those all work pretty well sure yeah
that that being able to connect your
controller wirelessly to different
devices right now it's such a chromecast
ultra those are just what that's just
one of the many features that are being
rolled out in this year later this year
or even in 2020 I mean we don't have to
go through the whole roster features
that are missing at the moment but those
are still being worked out so that's we
can't really comment on how those other
aspects weren't quite yet yeah and I
think largely stadia is probably still
being worked out you know the the outcry
from the community has been you know
this is not basically the technology is
great but it's hamstrung by this
expensive pricing model that Google has
built around it everyone is saying just
make this a you know a
subscription-based service or at least
make it free for now for the people who
have paid to get into this service and
obviously we're expensing games because
this is for work but I despite it
working well I couldn't imagine paying
full price for something like grid or
even half price for something like Final
Fantasy 15 yeah
these are old games the new technology
that still has a lot of room to grow how
was the launch lineup though because we
want to talk about games right because
we are a game spot we are its robust I
would say you could say you have two
fighting games you have Samurai Shodown
you have Mortal Kombat only one racing
game I think right I think we're is the
only racing game there are three Tomb
Raider games
I got thumper Just Dance those are the
rhythm games you've also got Youngblood
Destinee it mean honestly like it said
it's a good group of games but there's
hardly anything new there is that game
guilt I struggle to say anything good
about that game to be honest it's the
sort of thing that I feel like as a
launch title as an exclusive a bit
disappointing
I feel like Google I feel like it's one
of those signs that Google launched this
as soon as they could rather than when
the timing was right
sure and that's just speculation on my
part and there are a couple more games
that are coming out this year I know
we're gonna get a bunch of from Ubisoft
but again like like a lot of aspects of
stadia those are continually being
rolled out yeah
we're told every week actually like
that's what Google is twelve ready in
the recent past is that no it's gonna be
a regular cadence of releases you know
XYZ so I think it's gonna be really
telling to see what happens after that
first week in December when the pro
member discounts you know take over to
different discounts for the games they
currently have and any new ones they
introduced that is the biggest challenge
Google has right now because the tech
kind of speaks for itself and sure it's
a daresay cutting edge because we've had
streaming services before but to the
extent that it's like you know curated
and presented like it's pretty new and
nice so good job Google there but yeah
once the pricing model gets worked out
maybe I'll be ready to be truly excited
about this since we're talking about
games do we want to show a little bit of
gameplay in action live here see how it
works it's custom great let's hit the
grid hey we're here in San Francisco and
we're here in San Francisco so I'm just
gonna play a little bit see if I can and
you haven't played this yet I have play
this yet but I am a big racing game fan
so I'm gonna hit these corners quite
well I've been drove and driven much in
San Francisco so this is unrealistic all
of you look you can see um it's up the
Bay Bridge that's the Bay Bridge is that
the Bay Bridge Bay Bridge that's a
favorite Jack okay oh yeah this is this
is feeling it feels pretty good right so
yeah we're playing through a Chrome
browser right now we're connected
wireless Internet and to our corporate
network so you know with fast
[Music]
yeah like are you feeling like when you
turn it turns yeah yeah
Philip Prairie all right I play a lot of
forces of horizon old school gran
turismo was my bread and butter back in
the day so I'm familiar with how a
racing game should feel and I'm feeling
pretty all right but I'm also I'm washed
up as you can see I'm in 14th place
right so you talk about forts I played a
bit of I want to save forts of
motorsport I'm gonna forget the number 7
7 the one that's on Xbox game streaming
preview yeah and I have a lot of good
things to say about that that preview
program right now for Microsoft but
forts that did not play well wirelessly
on a strong connection where other games
had and I think that experience really
drove home for me how impressive the
grid working this way is because it's
honestly just as good here as it is at
home on my personal internet connection
and you know to kind of go back and talk
about something that came up last video
I have decided to unlock my data cap on
my internet at home which is costing me
an extra 50 bucks effectively raising my
bill by a little bit more than 50% and
it gives me peace of mind that I can
kind of enjoy stadia as much as I want
especially at 4k on the chromecast ultra
but I'm still waiting for that bill to
hit my mailbox and see you know that
added cost that is another consideration
that a lot of people have to you know
take into account before they jump into
stadia I had a research firm reach out
to me because they saw me bring that up
in my review in progress and they sent
me some data and is basically on the
different networks around the country
that you know have data caps on their
customers some of them are as low as
like 200 gigabytes a month that's only
10 hours of stadia at 4k dismissing all
of their internet usage so I guess we're
lucky that I only have or that I have at
least a terabyte to use without having
to raise my cap but even then that's
still cutting it close using the
chromecast so it's again coming back to
cost we brought it up on the last video
and again like I said I did the math and
yeah if you if you're playing again if
you're playing about three hours a day
throughout a month and that comes out to
like about 90 hours maybe a hundred if
you play a little bit more on the
weekends
yeah I mean a you need someone to keep
your gaming time in check but that's
that's pushing 2 terabytes and not many
of us have 2 terabytes to give no
especially when we're doing other things
throughout our days downloading other
stuff using the internet for work at
home yeah just a dia alone is gonna eat
up a lot of data yeah so I think with
all of that said it's clear that Google
has done some really good work with
stadia but the launch leaves a lot to be
desired and there's still a lot that we
want to see change and improve and
actually come to fruition Google has
promised many things that still are not
a part of the stadia experience so you
know my review is gonna hit it's just by
2019 review maybe I'll have another one
in 2020 either way we're gonna keep
covering stadia and other streaming
services so if that's something you're
interested in I mean you're not gonna be
able to escape it next year so stay
tuned the game spot for all your
streaming coverage news impressions
whatever you want we got it
[Music]
you
[Music]